bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fabi j
ed oggi siamo su amnesia the dark
descent ragazzi devo fare assolutamente
una custom storica appena uscita che in
seguito di un ergastolo storica avevo
già fatto che gli zar ding my eyes non
poteva non giocare il seguito perché non
so non so che cosa mi sarei persa adesso
andiamo a vela volo subito i due ragazzi
se non avete visto il prim cos'è run ok
vabbè potevi dirlo con più calma ma va
benissimo lo stesso
[Applauso]
avete presente beautiful
questo sarà molto meglio
non so non so spiegarvi che cazzo è sta
roba comunque
[Musica]
quando la musica si sta causando
il cazzo sono questi sei magari entro
stasera si riesce a fare qualcosa
ok perfetto ha finito vaio store e
caprini dei ragazzi che cosa cazzo sta
succedendo e ho sempre sognato di essere
nella colonna sonora di dragon ball
fantastico ragazzi e non vedevo lo siamo
sul tg5
[Musica]
buonasera e ben ritrovati qui dalle tgif
in apertura passiamo alla linea fa vj
grazie nuovi porter ragazzi siamo
partiti il nostro progetto l'armonia
allora questo ep dovrebbe chi è colpito
questo dovrebbe essere la stanza io ho
paura
cos'è sta roba frank schleck sono ideali
che cazzo stiamo è scritto in tedesco
comunque l'ho preso perchè volevo capire
chi cazzo è sto tizio ma che occhi
bellissimi cia non vi siete innamorati e
fantastica bonus e premi non nova è un
tizio da perdere la testa
ma l'avete capita perfetto e andiamo da
sto tizio che mi sembra molto più
abbordabile ciao giro tomic fronte
bashment perfetto andare a prendere il
latte per parla la missione è questa per
chi lo conosceva ragazzi di cielo
karting my eyes è una variante molto
simile ad amnesia vero cioè che fa
proprio paura
questo è il lazio per caso sono questa è
una bomba carta
non sapevo non mi ha preso però però
perfetto ragazzi devo trovare il latte
da qualche parte non so dove che sta
facendo questi è sporca
di merda e se l'ho fatto
non so come cazzo quarto ma va bene
buongiorno senti 0 e io non sapevo che
eri qui dietro mato liberato
quindi adesso ti metti nudo e mi dai
tuoi vestiti perché mi chiamo il solito
ranzoni sexy sono sexy colonie sono
settimane che valuti io adesso si pieghi
senti gestacci o cazzo perché è
diventato un cane ragazzi non ha senso
tutto gioco da ragazzi [ __ ] tutto io
sfondo ai muri io stiamo bene devo
portare in giro perché sono epiche
faccio saltare in area qualsiasi cosa
devo andare a buongiorno ho bisogno solo
di prendere il latte lo fate casini
ragazzi io vado giù anche fatto
malissimo buongiorno a questo accesso di
nuova generazione sentitemi ragazzi
adocchiato la carta igienica qui sopra
non soltanto si no sì sì ok renzi io ti
ho portato la carta da culo picchia se
l'è mangiata di brutto giorno che
qualcuno li ho bisogno del latte prego
ok ok che non va bene non ho paura da un
ok ma del latte grazie lo straniero nel
cesso ti ha dato il latte
io sinceramente ragazzi non accetterei
del latte da una mano che sbuca da un
cesso ma comunque va bene così grazie
mille
ok allora ragazzi dobbiamo uscire di
quanto ho portato il lato ho fatto un
casino per prendere almeno bevitore e
sai gaddam ma niente amico mio avviso
agli ordini nuovo per fare la tua adesso
questa bisogno di nuovo ma [ __ ]
c'è poi vuole sempre qualcosa dove lo
trovo l'uomo viene sta merda ti fai mai
cazzo vuoi quale chiavi c'ho le chiavi
perfetto mi mancavano regioni ragazzi
adesso posso partire e andare via da
questo posto bellissimo quindi per
ragazzi io non ho trovato un senso sta
mappa qualcuno se qualcuno di voi trova
un senso me lo dica perché io non ce
l'ho comunque va bene comunque va bene
verso l'infinito e provincia
grazie sappia che cosa stiamo facendo ma
va bene così e lo andrei mai in un posto
che mi sorride così male ve lo dico sul
corretto
noi siamo su un altro pianeta fantastico
cos'è che una roba la sua ragazzino
spazio paperone chi cazzo fai da te
vieni qui ma [ __ ] ragazzi e che
cazzo fa mi sta scoprendo passati dai
[ __ ] e non ha senso comunque vabbè
io prendo il suo gelato mira che a
questo è l'ultimo ci dovremmo essere poi
non fare il bacio concerto ci siamo zio
666 sazio scotti starcraft ii server va
bene papera scozzese ha lasciato serve
bene così che cazzo mi è servito da
rigirati a zio paperone qualcuno me lo
spiega spedito anche tu gelati sono
finiti mi dispiace
va bene allora ghazi non parlate i
goblin una game cube mi avete dato una
game cube fantastico ragazzi cosa mi
chiedevo se può metterla mica qui dentro
nintendo gamecube pezzo nel frattempo
sulla terra che cosa sta succedendo
questi bus a dwight howard che qualche
se fai del musp insistono da mezzi mia
moglie e io sono pochi giri e se giocano
giorgio sono solo casi rieste 11 cerci
che cazzo sta perché c'è blitz tranche
di diesel di league of legends che ci
posso fare
[ __ ] usala per farti le pippe
ragazzino
madonna mi ha quasi preso mica un
ceffone da colori balti trovi su marte
veramente cazzo vai cos'è chi è quel
tizio tutto e brutti veramente ragazzi
sono fantastici psicosi munus a e così è
pensi di farmi fuori così ma tu stai con
chi hai a che fare lurido sì ce lo
faccio ma dovrei aver fatta credo sì
anche perché io avevo il potere del
latte ancora la bottiglia non ci sono sì
ok ok ok ok ok ok perfetto ci sia altra
notte poi dover iniziare tutto daccapo e
basf angulo ok ci siamo noi non ancora
capito cos'è dovrebbe essere la terra in
teoria quella roba lì
ma non facciamoci domanda andiamo avanti
credo che siamo sulla luna
forse non lo so ma [ __ ] era
spuntato un magico
non lo so se comunque stavo dicendo
stiamo pian piano ritornando sulla terra
cosa che cazzo era sta roba
ok quanti ce ne sono
aspettate che ci sono mai così si si si
[ __ ] di stronzi olè olè
l'ultimo sì cazzo non protesta mai si si
si sono fatta non so come ma ce l'ho
fatto ok ok ragazzi non devo seccato
adesso lancio di tutto il monitor
tastiera tutto perché ci ho messo
mezz'ora poi chi è quel vizio ma
inquietantissimo cos'è sta roba
salve senti oggi se mi fai cadere tipico
una banana nell'occhio che si son messo
mezz'ora di pazienza quant'è brutto ciao
ragazzi ha saltato via di brutto non mi
interessa torniamo indietro
ce la possiamo fare c'è di nuovo il
camion cioè di nuovo il camion chiamò
ragazzi ci sono due strade dove diavolo
vado adesso io vado di qua vado di qua
perché voglio andarmene via da sto posto
di me stavo cadendo non importa facciamo
finta di niente
ok ce la posso fare vado di qua perché
voglio uscire dai dalle palle il prima
possibile perché sono avrei preso
l'altra porta ultimo salto sì sì ce
l'abbiamo fatta
ce l'abbiamo fatta via di qui apriti
maledetto dove cazzo a domandargli la
forza ok ok non hai le chiavi
sì sì sì ce l'ho ce l'ho ce l'abbiamo
fatta mezz'ora per correre davanti aste
merde che cazzo sta succedendo che
stiamo andando col camion
ragazzi questa è la terra più in alta
definizione che io abbia mai visto in
vita mia e ve lo dico non ho mai visto
la terra rappresentata meglio c'è questa
è chiaramente la rappresentazione
migliore a pensavo si schiantasse di
botto non lo so ci siamo
[Musica]
ragazzi siamo a prepararsi
all'atterraggio olè olè ce l'abbiamo
fatta
ce l'abbiamo fatta siamo atterrati in
teoria pensavo che quelle casette pian
piano diventassero più grandi invece
sono rimaste piccole ma che se ne frega
siamo tornati a casa l'importante questo
e sono veramente ansioso di rivedere
chuck norris nel seminterrato
però prima devono non devo andare di qua
infatti di andare dall'altra parte un
giorno allora ragazzi
l'ultima volta che ho fatto sta cosa qua
c'era una festa a sorpresa
io non so che cazzo ci può essere adesso
[Musica]
jack che cazzo ci fai ciak perché c'è la
tizia di burella gun che sta suonando il
pianoforte li alquanto sexy date mica
cosa per rimorchiare un qualsiasi cosa
in casa se vuoi un cucciolo ragazzi e di
vaio paperone ti lo zio paperone un
velociraptor che cazzo ci fanno brilla
per quello di ieri di happy meals
giacché dammi una mano che c'è la tizia
per questi due stanno
facciamo finta di niente per quei tizi
che stanno facendo il loro cazzo di como
di ragazzi ce la possiamo fare
ok il credo sia finito non penso a un
team di più
basta continua xvi perché ballano sul
tavolo stipsi altro che cazzo hanno
assunto di medicinali ber
va a ballare come del mondo plastici sul
tavolo ma va bene così i ragazzi mi
piace troppo
ce l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi conclude più
l'episodio perché se avete un senso a
quello che avete appena visto l'invito a
scriverlo nei commenti perché non ce
l'ho trovato per niente ogni mi piace al
vito è un neurone in più per quello che
ha creato suo livello comunque ragazzi è
il vino è piaciuto come al solito sconto
metto mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook che come noi video trovata una
vestizione ieri sera per iscritti
iscrivetevi di ci rivediamo in un
prossimo video per ragazzi